hey guys my name is clinton jones and i
want to show you how you can add any 3d
character to your custom motion capture
data now this may seem like a very
specific thing but i'm currently running
a render challenge where i'm providing
you with this animation
and challenging you to build it out
however you see fit one of the biggest
questions i received so far
is how do i switch out the character
model so i'll show you how to do that
how you would do it if you're trying to
use a custom photo scan that you may
have created yourself
and even how to animate extra movement
on top of the current animation
so let's start by slapping a miximo
character onto this custom data that i
recorded with my rococo motion capture
suit
once you find the character you like
let's search for t-pose
select it and export this data the
reason we want our character in t-pose
is because frame
0 of our custom mocap data is also in
t-pose
and is the easiest way to combine an
animated skeleton in a static character
together otherwise you'd have to
manually tweak every single joint
most mocap softwares offer the frame
zero t-pose as an option
and rococo studio does this by default
now once you have your animated skeleton
and your static character mesh stacked
on top of each other in cinema 4d the
goal is to pair the skeleton movement to
the character mesh
it works best when the joints are lined
up as close as possible
notice how the thumbs are off and this
will be a good example of
a glitchy kind of look here you guys
will see it once we pair them up
let's give both joints a character
definition tag
in the tag let's select open manager
we'll extract skeleton
and set reference pose what we're doing
is telling c4d to look at the hierarchy
of joints as they are
and lock them in as our base pose when
we follow the exact same steps for the
other joint structure
extract skeleton and set reference pose
we now have two animated joints on the
same playing field
ready to communicate with each other to
connect them let's select the character
definition tag on our miximo joints
and select create solver then we'll drag
the character definition tag from our
custom mocap data
into the source character slot and bam
look at that we are connected
hey i want to give a quick shout out to
my gaming audience and as a big gamer
myself i'm proud to announce that
today's video is sponsored by world of
warships world of warships is a
free-to-play team-based sea
strategy game available for pc the game
features over 400 beautifully modeled
customizable ships that you can command
through unique terrain you guys know i'm
a fan of atmosphere in all my renders so
naturally i dig the weather changing
system they've integrated
into the game world of warships
currently has more than 44 million
players worldwide
and four different warship types to
choose from destroyers which rely on
speed and maneuverability
battleships are the heavies with thick
armor and huge guns the cruiser is your
well-rounded attack and defense ship
and guys don't forget the aircraft
carriers those are the masters of recon
and surprise airstrikes so dive in and
download world of warships using the
link in the description
and use the promo code boom during
registration to unlock 200 balloons
two ships the saint louis and the
premium emdin ship along with 20 times
restless fire camo 2.5 million credits
and
seven days of a premium account but
notice those thumbs though the closer
the joints are to each other in t-pose
the better the end result we can zero
out those values and rotate the thumb a
bit
to clean it up but what if miximo
doesn't have the character you want to
use
what if you want to photo scan yourself
and connect that to the custom mocap
data
upload your photo scan to miximo and
take advantage of their auto rig feature
it's wonderful
line up all the joints and you'll get an
auto rigged auto animated version of
yourself
pretty sweet just throw it in t-pose
export it and follow the steps we just
went
over to get it moving but we're not done
because what if you want to adjust the
animated rig for whatever reason or
maybe
you want to add some additional
animation on top of the already animated
character
select the custom mocap data that's
driving your character mesh go to
animate
and let's add a motion clip make sure
you uncheck the remove
included animation from original object
checkbox and let's just hit ok
press shift f3 to open up your timeline
and switch over to motion clip view
where we can see our layer here
let's select the motion tag on our
animated skeleton and add a layer
and let's make sure to drag it above the
original layer
i'll rename this to arm movement so if
we grab the arm joint
adjust it and make a keyframe this will
be the new position for the arms and you
can animate them over time by adding
more keyframes this can be done for any
part of the animated skeleton
but keep in mind if you're participating
in the alternate realities competition
you can only adjust the shoulders down
don't touch anything else
so if you guys want to participate in
the internet's most epic
cg challenge then check out this video
right up here and if y'all like this
quick tip
style video then leave a comment down
below let me know what you guys would
like to learn
next in this short time frame until then
i'll see you guys on my saturday morning
cg live streams
where i'm currently building out the
most ambitious environment i've ever
created
see you guys soon peace
[Music]
you